what a selection any recommendations
yeah drink somewhere else what can I get
you
let's go with something sweet
deceptively strong with lots of ice
Shirley Temple coming right up what is a
nice girl with two doctorates in a PhD
doing in a rat's nest like this one
working how'd you find me I'm great with
computers and I have my own satellite
you do the math you vibed me I find you
yes you're looking a lot less frosty
than the last time I saw you you said
you weren't her but you weren't in
Kaitlin either it's just me Cisco I'm
just Caitlin how'd you do it what do you
want well a stiffer drink for starters
if you're back to normal I have to know
why don't you come back to us okay I get
it
that's fine I'm not gonna make you
answer that what we really could have
used you are you still stuck in the
Speed Force you know about that I'm
gonna get him out but I need your help
anything okay
everything's fine yeah everything's
great pal do you mind I'm talking to the
lady I'm sure there's someone else you
could find in here to commiserate with
over poor life choices
[Music]
thank you look I figured out how to save
Barry but I can't do it without you
everybody the flashes back that finally
posts a new footage so let's break this
down and there is a new round of the
Justice League ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
explain the giveaway stuff at the end of
the video too but this just tees up that
cisco has the plan and explains what
killer frost has been doing this whole
time in you know technically she lies a
little bit about being killer frost it's
still in there inside her she just
deflects when he's like how did you do
it she just turns away I am her but you
learn a little bit about what's happened
since then like Caitlin wasn't around
when Barry went into the Speed Force but
I think that she just heard about it
from everyone else like crime slowly
goes back up and that's why it's so
important that they get him back out
because they love their friend but it's
like Batman leaving Gotham City crime
doubles overnight when criminals know
that Batman isn't around so just the
idea of having the flash around is a
deterrent to metahumans but like you see
this really greasy looking dude here
standing next to Cisco he brushes him
off Cisco is actually pretty powerful
but the way Caitlin looks at him makes
it seem like he's actually pretty
dangerous because she has powers of her
own too so if she respects someone's
power even if she doesn't like them it
means that they're probably a pretty
serious threat but I love the idea that
she's been working in a dive bar this
whole time and a lot of you did asked
when they released those pictures like
why is Caitlin with two PhDs working in
this dive bar it's probably just because
she hates herself and she's so torn up
over what's happened the last couple of
seasons they did say it's not gonna be a
super bummer all season long like the
implies it's something really heavy is
going on inside her she hasn't dealt
with yet but they're actually
capitalizing on a lot of that trauma and
her working through it for some comedy
with what's going on with the other
characters so like people will have
problems and team flash personal
problems and Caitlin will be like I
actually went through that so she'll
actually have something to offer beyond
all the science that she contributes in
the stuff that she does as killer frost
when she has powers but just guessing
from Cisco's comments this takes place
relatively early in the episode
but after he talks to Iris and they have
that argument about bringing Barry back
I want to bring him back and iris is
like no I don't think that we should is
even still alive but Cisco just flat out
refuses to accept that idea so I don't
think they're gonna waste too much time
and getting to that but you do have the
idea that the samurai is asking for the
flash so Wally has to stand in so that's
probably all after they've brought Barry
bag like he's still chilling out being
all three-eyed raven they're having
trouble communicating with him and then
as things devolve into a shitstorm he
finally gets it together puts the new
costume on and saves the day
so by episode 2 he's relatively back to
normal flash but they did say that
they're sort of easing in to bringing
everybody back so if you're wondering
about what's going on with Harrison
wells how he's coming back it's gonna be
earth to Harrison Wells but he won't
really be back till I think even the
third episode like he might pop up at
the end of the second episode and Jessie
quick is off somewhere else she's still
on the show she'll come back but I don't
think that she's going to pop up the
first half of the season it a lot of you
have started messaging me about what's
going on with the two-part episode 13
episode 14 story in the back half of the
season if they're gonna do a reverse
flash origin story I don't know anything
about that I do know that they'll
probably do a two-part episode for
episode of 13 in episode 14 again and I
don't think that it's gonna be Gorilla
Grodd again because he's going to
legends of tomorrow Wally West is also
going to legends of tomorrow so that
explains why he hasn't been in the last
couple of episodes of the flash he's
been off doing other stuff so it just
sounds like he goes away after the first
couple of episodes and then winds up in
one or two episodes of legends of
tomorrow I don't know how long he's
gonna be on that show but I don't think
that he's gonna be a permanent cast
member but we did learn that we're
actually going to get Inklings of what's
going on with a thinker in the first
couple of episodes he's gonna start
making Barry run the gauntlet throwing
different metas at him so I think that
that confirms in a roundabout way that
he's responsible for the samurai in
episode 1 he says I'm looking for the
flash as he grabs iris and tries to draw
him out the whole idea with the thinker
this season is that he needs Barry for a
very specific reason so
that's why I think the samurai tasks for
the flash like we haven't seen in them a
while he's very important to the
thinker's plan so I'm going to threaten
the person that I know that he loves and
that will bring him back so we'll talk
about that when I post my Easter Egg
video later tonight but what will happen
is as I'll announce the Justice League
ticket giveaway winner when I post that
I might have an extra video to post
depending on how long it takes me to get
that Easter egg video out so if you want
video updates you can follow me on
Twitter and Facebook for when videos are
gonna post those links are down in the
description but because all the DC TV
shows are back this week there'll be new
ticket giveaways in each of them it'll
be like extra giveaway stuff going on
through Justice League's release at the
end of November so don't worry plenty of
stuff going on and there'll be a bunch
of Justice League stuff dropping in the
background if it's relevant to the flash
stuff then I'll work it into videos but
otherwise I'll just do separate Justice
League videos for that so just a heads
up my legends episode one video will
post tomorrow in my arrow video which is
now a Thursday show will post Thursday
nights so I'll just remind people as I
post new videos make sure you turn
alerts on for video uploads on my
channel so you don't miss anything but
while you wait for everything you can
click here for more new flash and you
can click here for that brand new
Justice League trailer again thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight